this morning is part of our eye on earth
series we go to northern Italy where
parts of a massive glacier near the
famed Mont Blanc are at risk of collapse
officials watching the melting glacier
have ordered emergency measures to keep
people in the remote region safe
Seth Doan is in Italy near Mont Blanc
Seth what's happening there good morning
Tony officials have closed off part of
this road and have declared several of
the mountain homes along it off-limits
as they are concerned that ice could
break off from this glacier that massive
ice and snow right up there it's this
left-hand side of the glacier that
you're concerned about geologist Daniele
Jordan was one of the Italian government
researchers to sound the alarm
it doesn't look so big from where we're
standing this is a probable point of
view
in fact the chunk of ice they're worried
could fall is about as big as two
football fields and nearly eight stories
high this is a ground-based radar it
works also during the night of if it is
cloudy he showed us a radar system
they're using to monitor the movement of
planned penso glacier at the foundation
for a safe Mountain a team of Italian
government scientists are poring over
the data which is also coming from
drones and satellites
you see the difference between yesterday
and today you see where all the ice
fills up here jean-pierre Faison
explains how rapid melting caused by
warmer temperatures is making the
glacier slide and a glacier speak it's
speeding 24 inches per day it's a lot
for glacier it's a lot the Sun is in
charge of mountain safety in this area
which includes the picturesque tourist
destination of gourmet or where folks
are not in danger but are watching
closely when do you think this might
happen you have to call God because you
cannot say when it falls
but Faison says the culprit is clear
climate change the great problem for the
glacier is not the
one day of high temperatures instead is
the continuous of eye temperatures night
and they appear on Mont Blanc at an
elevation of more than 11,000 feet we
got a closer look at these glaciers
massive frozen rivers of ice there are
about 30 glaciers here on the Italian
side of Mont Blanc and all of them are
melting in fact in the last 50 years
Italian glaciers have lost about 40
percent of their mass and this is a
global problem melting glaciers have led
activists to stage funerals all across
the Alps for the disappearing ice sheets
Daniella Jordan told us it is not
unusual from a geological perspective of
course to see ice breaking off a glacier
what is unusual here is that it's
breaking off so close to people and Gail
he said we should expect to see more of
this as the climate continues to change
oh boy thank you very much Seth Doane
reporting from Italy you know it's
serious if the answer is called God to
get the yeah well they're taking
emergency measures to protect people at
the bottom of the glacier
when does the the globe take an
emergency measure against the warming
itself actually 40 percent of the mass
loss they're just in those glaciers
amazing